foreign
what started out as a routine traffic
stop turns into a major drug bust when
Oklahoma officers discover hundreds of
marijuana plants in the back of a moving
van
body cameras captured it all on video
when Seminole police officer Billy
Messner pulled over a Penske moving
truck for making multiple traffic
violations
freestyle pulled you over one you're
running about 25 30 miles under the
speed limit and then you cross this
white line twice
no I didn't yes you did Sir I was right
behind you the whole time but it wasn't
the driver's speed that proved to be
cause for concern all right sir well I'm
waiting on the return
I'm gonna take my dog I'm gonna run it
around the vehicle if you can just shut
the vehicle off and keep your windows
rolled up
and before we run is there any illegal
narcotics marijuana meth heroin or
cocaine
the driver 46 year old bun Wong then
hands officer Messner paperwork
ultimately telling him there's weed in
the back of the vehicle so is it
full-size plants
they're just plants though you got a
Transportation license too uh I don't
have it with me
man that's illegal officer Messner tells
Wong the transport is illegal without a
Transportation license
you gotta
you gotta have the transportation
everything is legal not if you don't
have a transportation license
I don't have that uh
and you don't have the transport license
either
it's then that Wong voluntarily opens
the back of the moving van revealing
222 marijuana plants you mind if I open
the back up or do you want to open the
back okay you can if you want yes sir
so sick
okay
just plants all the way to the top
good it's gracious how many is supposed
to be there uh 150.
Wong tells officer Messner he came from
Okemah Oklahoma but the directions don't
add up it's coming from where
she's coming from Okemah
I think so because uh
well you didn't come from Mokena
yes I stopped by something that someone
has well I mean you stop way out of the
way okay is like way
over there officer Messner quickly
radios for backup saying Wong's story
isn't straight I got roughly 150 plants
but everything he's saying is not adding
up to what his manifest is saying when
other officers arrive officer Messner
explains the situation
he doesn't have transportation license
but then he come back then he hollered
at me and he said my lawyer helped me do
this and he showed me something on his
phone I said let's go back up there and
sit down and we'll be with you his
lawyer yeah all this happened on January
11th and that date is important what is
today's
date
my guess is it's all fake is all get out
yeah it looks like it
this manifest was created on 112.
created the future bill
I was like
and it was after this time so I looked
down and I watched us at 11. look clean
next officer Messner tells Wong he's
being detained and explains why
well you can have them send that to you
but right now you're going to be
detained for not having a transport
license because you don't have a
transport license my boss has it you
have to have the transfer lights whoever
is transporting has to be in this truck
that's a license
one don't have a locked door two you
don't have a transport license you don't
have the Grower's license or anything
like that with you so he's going to
transport you back to the PD for me
later officers compare what Wong told
them about his Transportation Route with
what's written on his paperwork when I
asked him about that any narcotics he
just
and I looked at it I was like
listen where you headed because right
down here all right words right down
here is there even in Nowata Oklahoma
is it yeah
two hours and it's 140 miles away he's
heading the wrong way too yeah he's
going around
after that officers
Tire vehicle
officer Messner follows as the moving
van is taken into storage Wong was
charged with cultivation of a controlled
substance he's due in court on March 2nd
for a status hearing reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie